Guys, speaking of retweeting,
it is Tuesday.
It's time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we --
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that
we should post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets,
and we're all gonna vote on
whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You can see them right there.
Yeah.
I love the people acting like
they didn't see the clickers
when they sat down.
They're the only things there.
Yeah, they're right there, yeah.
You can vote for all of them,
by the way.
And you can also vote
for none of them.
Whatever. I just want
you to have a good
time, enjoy yourself.
We're gonna see
the results live.
We have a very expensive
machine we paid like...
-Really?
-...$25 to $30 for.
-Really?!
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's an old laptop.
Remember Gateway computers?
-Oh, it's a Gateway?
-Yeah, yeah.
It's an old Gateway laptop,
and that's hooked
into this polling system.
-Yeah. 8 bits.
-But it's real.
Higgins, you have your clicker?
-Got my clicker.
-Roots, clickers?
-Yep, all done.
-Perfect.
Whatever tweet gets the most
likes, we will tweet it out
live on the show
during commercial break.
So you can all like it
and WeTweet it.
[ Cheers ]
It's a shared experience.
Alright.
You guys ready for this?
Our first tweet is...
[ Light laughter ]
I --
-Come on.
-Yeah, I like it.
I don't know --
I don't quite know
what it means.
But I like it.
Alright.
Thumbs up, thumbs down.
Quest, this is the first time
I've ever seen you
not just say yes to it.
-I'm gonna say yes
'cause I like my job but --
I don't get it.
-You'd rather just say no.
-Well, the votes are in. Let's
see the results on this one.
Whoa. Look at that! Not bad!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-That one's got potential.
That was 138?
-1-3-8.
-1-3-8. Hold on a second.
-[ Higgins squeaking ]
-Alright, here we go.
I don't need -- I don't need
sound effects for the mar--
-[ Higgins squeaking ]
-Alright.
This next one here is...
[ Laughter ]
At that point...
-That's a speaker.
-Yeah.
At that point, it's a bop.
Alright, I feel like
everyone made their decision
on that one pretty quick.
Let's see the results.
-Oh.
-Ooh.
[ Applause ]
-[ Higgins squeaking ]
1-2-4. Not so good.
-No, no, no. Not too good.
Alright.
How about this next one here?
It says...
[ Laughter ]
-Come on. That's cute.
-Boo!
-Hm. I got a -- Someone booed.
-Yeah. I think they think
it's more cute than funny.
Is that what you're saying?
-Alright.
-Alright. What do you got?
-Let's see the results
on this one.
-Whoa!
-I like it.
-1-4-8. That's the topper.
-1-4-8. That's not bad.
-That's the topper now,
isn't it?
-Yeah, that's the topper. The
first one means nothing to me.
-Yeah.
-Uh, this one --
Oh, I like this one.
Next up, it goes...
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
-That's a thinker.
-That's a thinker,
but it's funny.
And, you know what,
if you like comedy...
-Yeah, that's the way to go.
-It's something --
-You couldn't finish the tweet
'cause you fell into a.
-That's -- Well, that's what --
But I'll -- You --
I wouldn't put that
in your mouth --
You were putting
those words in --
-You, co-author of the piece.
Yeah.
-Comedy prop.
-Hole -- Manhole.
You fell right in it.
-Yes.
-With a banana peel.
[ Rim shot ]
-Let's see the results
on that one.
Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about!
Yes!
-1-6-3!
-I agree.
I don't know if we're
gonna top that one.
Uh, no,
I don't think we'll top it.
-You think so?
-I don't know.
What do you think, Tariq?
-I think we can
definitely top that one.
I think that one was
low-hanging fruit.
-Low-hanging fruit.
-Oh, "low-hanging fruit."
-Is this the last one?
-Yeah.
-Come on. Like --
-Come on, people.
-I think we can do it, guys.
No matter what it is,
let's make this one...
-Yeah, make this one the winner.
-Like, yeah,
let's make this one the winner.
Like, make it count.
It's November 1st
up in this bitch.
Let's do this.
-You can't do that.
You can't buy the audience.
-What? I'm not buying --
I'm not paying them.
-Make them decide --
They decide on their own.
-What do I look like,
the Tooth Fairy?
I'm not buying the audience.
-Yeah, you're, like, telling
them what to vote for. No.
-Okay, look.
Do what you want to do.
-You're wearing sunglasses.
No one can even see --
-Well, that's why
it was overexaggerated.
-I couldn't even tell if you're
winking or what you were doing.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. This last one is...
"I can always tell
if I'm not gonna like someone
based on how accurately they
pronounce the word 'cruh-SONT.'"
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Now you think it's rigged,
no matter what happens.
-No. I don't -- I don't know.
People are laughing
in the audience, but...
-You think they were
browbeaten into laughing?
-What was the other one
that was 148?
Oh, no, 163. What was that one?
Oh. "Fall into a."
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I think "Fall into a."
-Right.
-But that's me, personally.
-Right. You personally.
It's your tweet.
-And then this one is which one?
Cruh-SONT?
-This was how accurately
they say the word cruh-SONT.
-Or -- Or -- Or as Jimmy
would say -- KWAH-SAH.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. What do you think, Higgs?
-I think -- I don't know.
I think this one is not as good,
but it might win.
[ Laughter ]
-He just trying
to cover all bases.
-Yeah.
-Tariq, you think this one's --
Do you agree with Higgins?
-This one's through the roof.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-"Yeah."
Let's see the results.
-Ohh!
-We did it!
We did it! We did it!
-Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh.
Wow! Oh, my gosh.
They love you. That's why.
-My people, my people.
-I will post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a WeTweet, and enjoy.